this is now hurricane ida what it looks  like from space wow astronaut megan  macarthur tweeted these images from  aboard the international space station  and sally you can see from these images  just the magnitude of that storm and  especially louisiana they had katrina a  long time ago definitely a very you know  dangerous situation right and we're also  tracking moisture from hurricane nora  that could potentially bring us  increased rain chances here to the las  vegas valley this is why we're letting  you know that the monsoonal moisture is  pushing through and we're going to track  that for you right now let's check out  those current conditions sasha we are  checking out a pretty gusty camera  outside right now